i'm looking at your fans out there and
they're like i love seeing swifties
right because there's nothing like them
and so today you're giving them so many
gifts right so many loves um you got
your new music red your version that's
out today and i know it's been really
important for you to own your own music
and above that you've also been a real
champion for other artists to own their
own music as well so what was it like
going back and visiting that era and
doing it all over again it was an
amazing experience and
one of the things about
the whole discussion over music
ownership is that
this was something that started out as a
really hard thing i went through
the fans are the people who turned it
into something very empowering where
when they they were just saying to me
over and over again we want to listen to
your versions if you redo it that's what
we'll listen to so if they hadn't if
they hadn't done that i don't think i'd
be having this amazing
exciting experience of being here and
you're here and there's a short film of
one of my favorite songs i've ever
written and so that's all the fans doing
and so this is really i just wanted to
think about what could i do over the
course of one week that would make them
as happy
or try to make them as happy as they've
made so listen you gave 30 songs first
of all you didn't just say let me do a
little something for the fans you say
here baby here's the whole play
exactly 30 songs 30 songs you gave them
a 10 minute long recording of all too
well i mean that's going to make people
maximalism
it's just a lot of a lot yeah and then
the short film yes oh my god out today
okay so let's dive into this recipe real
quick i saw it
come on
when you step into this because you
didn't just you wrote this you directed
it you're in it all of those things and
you cast this so i mean think about
everything that you did and what was
that like that process for you well it
was it was as all-consuming as writing a
song is i i really
directing i i felt as fulfilled by it as
i did when i craft a song and think
about every aspect of it and it comes
together and then it goes out in the
world there are so many moving pieces
um but honestly the actors sadie and
dylan
they just gave everything and i trusted
them so much because i've watched
everything they've done i've been a fan
of theirs for ages and so i knew
i knew
i had i had a feeling if you put these
two people in a room and you trust their
instincts
magical things could happen they were
electric in this i really just am so
proud of those performances and
i'm proud of how it looks and i'm proud
of how it feels to watch it and i i
really really hope the fans like it as
much as i do they're going to lose their
minds they really are going to lose
their minds last night on fallon you
said too that um the red album in its
entirety was sort of like a heartbroken
person right and you had so much better
of an experience recording at this time
so what would you then say to that
taylor who wrote all those songs back i
would say their fans are singing out
there they're singing like a chorus
i would just say i would say that's
gonna happen like there's there's
hundreds of people singing the words i
can't even take them
that's so they're way they're waiting i
see you right there i feel a lot of
things around yeah i would just show i
would play a video of that that gave me
and be like that's gonna happen you
collaborated again with your best friend
ed sharon yes your bestie is yes what
was that like getting back in with him
and how you guys have evolved over the
years together collaboration well we
hang out all the time and what's been so
great is watching him as an artist and
as a person and he you know we've both
been through so many changes but
it stays the same with us like it's one
of those friendships where it the
friendship doesn't move even when life
moves
yeah he's a wonderful wonderful friend
he's you know he's always there when i
need to talk it's nice to have someone
who has the same kind of stresses and
and and sort of
challenges in life you know
so yeah i love him i love it you got
chris and phoebe as well on oh my gosh
yes chris stapleton and phoebe bridgers
like the just like the
the star players of music right now like
how lucky am i
[Music]